vamos a seguir buscando anti derivadas
de las funciones básicas que es lo que
voy a hacer en este vídeo pero antes que
nada quiero que veas que este tipo de
anti derivadas o de integrales
indefinidas no forzosamente tienen que
ser con respecto a x como son operadores
depende de con respecto a qué variables
vas a integrar o anti derivar que en
este caso es de t y fíjate que no
siempre vamos a tener diferencial de x
en este caso de hecho tenemos
diferencial de t y bueno ahora sí voy a
separar primero esta anti derivada oeste
integral indefinida en cada uno de sus
suman 2 y me queda la integral
indefinida del seno de t diferencial de
tema más de integral indefinida del
coste no de t diferencial de t recuerda
que en el vídeo pasado vimos que
podíamos hacer esto con las anti
derivadas las anti derivadas abren sumas
ya brasil para resolver esta anti
derivada lo que me voy a preguntar es lo
siguiente cuál es la función que al
derivar la me da el seno de tema y bueno
yo sé que la derivada con respecto a t
del coste de 9 t es igual al menos seno
de tema
ojo aquí casi tengo el 120 lo único que
me falta es un signo de menos x
voy a poner este signo de menos aquí y
si ahora derivó en la misma función
solamente que negativa es decir la
derivada del menos coseno de t y
entonces esto se convierte en positivo y
ahora sí fíjate lo que dice aquí la
derivada con respecto a t del menos
conociendo de t es igual al seno de
temps o dicho de otra manera pensado en
el lenguaje las anti derivadas cuál es
la función que al derivar la medida
siendo dt y la respuesta pues es el
menos coseno de t y ya con esto logramos
resolver la primera anti derivada y de
manera muy análoga voy a resolver la
segunda si yo derivó con respecto a t el
c9 t me da el coste no de temp
haciéndome la misma pregunta cuál es la
función que al derivar la medal coseno
de temp y la respuesta es el seno de t y
ya con esto obtuvimos la solución o la
anti derivada del primer integral en la
segunda tengo la integral de ella la más
uno entre a diferencial de t
no no no no lo voy a borrar porque tiene
que ser con la variable de integración a
porque todo está inscrito con respecto
aa si no estas serían constantes y la
verdad no quiero hacerte más bolas
voy a poner diferencial de a ver si
empezamos de nuevo quiero la integral de
alarmas 1 / a diferencial de am y bueno
usando la misma propiedad que usted aquí
arriba lo primero que voy a hacer es
separar la integral en 2 suman 2 y me
queda la integral de la diferencial de
amd que es esta de aquí más el segundo
sumando es decir más la integral de 1 /
a más la integral de 1 / a diferencia
del de a y ahora sí lo primero que me
voy a preguntar es cómo resuelvo la
primera integral y para esto voy a hacer
memoria y voy a recordar que la derivada
con respecto a x de ea la x es lo mismo
que la x recuerden que esta función era
muy buena onda porque su derivada era
ella misma por lo tanto bueno aquí es
con respecto a x si yo quisiera ver con
respecto a tendría que la derivada con
respecto a de a la pues es lo mismo que
a la am depende con respecto a que estoy
derivando o con respecto a quien estoy
integrando y bueno les contaba que la
función exponencial es a todo dar porque
sus derivadas ella misma y que cree en
su integral sería misma
en aquí se cometió un error enorme me
faltó la constante que no se les olvide
la constante jajaja lo primero que les
digo lo primero que hago no se les
olvide la constante siempre al integrar
o al sacar una entidad derivada hay que
poner una constante de integración y
ahora sí cuál es la función que al
derivar la meda alam pues la respuesta
es salaam recuerdan que es una función
sencilla de derivar y de integrar y
después tengo la anti derivada de 1
entre a que como lo habíamos visto en el
vídeo pasado es el logaritmo natural del
valor absoluto de esta variable a más
una constante de integración y ya hemos
acabado aquí lo tenemos ya con eso
resolvimos las dos integrales que
teníamos que resolver en este vídeo y lo
logramos usando la derivada y la anti
derivada de las funciones
trigonométricas exponenciales básicas